si les numéros que vous avez mis en
place pour le harcèlement ils sont comme
la cellule contre le harcèlement la
cellule écoute je pense que pour ma part
ça n'a servi à rien mais j'espère que à
l'avenir ça servira pour pour d'autres
et qui seront quand même plus écouté que
parce que moi j'ai pas été écoutés mais
si vous avez appelé
s'est rien passé on a appelé mais la
cellule elle est censée être
pour les élèves harcelés pour les
n'existait pas au moment où ça vous
arrive et c'est pour ça
que je parle de mesures qui sont des
mesures à ces nouvelles finalement oui
mais au final si les numéros c'est
pareil bah ça sympa quelque chose les
mettre en place c'est comme afficher des
maîtres les affiches dans les couloirs
du collège contre le harcèlement si au
final on en parle et qu'on n'ait pas
écouté ça sert à rien et vraiment agir
et pas juste mettre des affiches par les
ans parce que c'est plus facile à dire
qu'à faire mais si on n'est pas écouté
ça sert à rien
n'a jamais eu une seule chose qui est
suffisante sur ses sommets jamais il
faut faire les affiches il faut faire
les numéros qu'il ya plein de choses à
faire mais jamais une seule chose
suffisant mais à la fin c'est pour ça
que je disais tout à l'heure il faut
écouter ce qu'on fait ce soir il faut
donc c'est effectivement nécessaire mais
les numéros j'étais tout à l'heure un
autre en vain je peux vous dire il
écoute il assure le suivi et s'appelle
l'académie pour ensuite aller dans
l'établissement on
sait la situation à l'époque elle est
vraiment pas parfaite je suis le premier
à le dire mais je pense qu'elle est en
voie d'amélioration mais en voie
d'amélioration parce qu'il ya des des
jeunes comme vous qui qui parle
justement donc c'est important de le
faire tiquer maintenant j'espère qu'on
va encore progresser ces prochains temps
grâce aux soins mais la justice après ça
il doit bouger aussi oui il faut
voilà mais pour moretti avec plaisir si
venir le garde des sceaux dans cette
émission ce sera bien sûr avec plaisir
qu'on le recevra et on peut même faire
une émission avec des des jeunes et le
garde des sceaux y aura aucun souci